[Music]
hello everybody very good morning to the
leader of a political party pursued by a
mob pearling abuse about the pedophile
jimmy savile the scene from our streets
last night secure starman walked through
westminster the prime minister accused
by some of his own mps of fueling it
we'll ask labour what they make of it
joined today also by the shadow mental
health minister dr rosanna allen khan
and for the government the minister for
technology chris philp it is tuesday the
8th of february
fresh pressure on the prime minister to
withdraw his comments as a mob shouting
slurs about jimmy savile across the
labour leader zakir stammer
a former director of public prosecutions
mr speaker
he spent most of his time prosecuting
journalists and failing to prosecute
jimmy savile
it is a ridiculous slur peddled by
right-wing trolls
lengthy discussions president putin
warns europe may be dragged into
military conflict if ukraine joins nato
and here in kiev the diplomacy continues
to prevent a russian invasion president
emmanuel macron of france meeting his
ukrainian counterpart president zelensky
animal lovers look away now deeply sorry
the west ham united player who's
apologized as video emerges of him
kicking and slapping his tiny pet cat
curling queen will speak to the captain
of the gold medal winning team gb
curling team who kept the nation up late
at the winter olympics 20 years ago as
this year's hopefuls try their luck in
beijing
also on the programme for you this
morning
[Music]
uh after her dramas in vegas adele is
back at the brits tonight we'll tell you
why it's all changed for the award
categories
and otter camp why there's a wake-up
call for otters as welch rivers see an
unexpected decline in numbers
[Music]
good morning good morning let's get
right to it should we the minister
brighton early hello thanks so much
indeed for joining us on the programme
this morning i know you're here to talk
about online abuse um and we will get to
that but first i want to talk about the
abuse of kyocera last night the labour
leader surrounded by protesters let's
remind people of what happened
[Music]
member of parliament least of all the
leaders of the opposition should be
surrounded by
a mob as we're seeing now on your screen
uh clearly subjecting him to harassment
and intimidation that has no place in a
democracy
and i think all of us across the
political spectrum should unreservedly
uh condemn what we saw there i think the
police made a couple of arrests which
i'm i'm glad to hear uh but no one in
public life should face that sort of
intimidation and harassment at all is
completely unacceptable this is why it
happened boris johnson in the house
this leader of the opposition a former
director of public prosecutions mr
speaker
he spent most of his time prosecuting
journalists and failing to prosecute
jimmy savile
i should apologize well look i don't
think you can say that's why it happened
because some of the people involved in
that um that fracker you showed a second
ago you know that they were have
previously you know they were talking
about have previously done similar
things to people like michael gove and
bbc journalist uh nick what
i've listened to i've listened i've
listened to the whole tape i've listened
to the whole tape and they did mention
jimmy savile they did mention that they
also mentioned julian assange repeatedly
they mentioned
uh covid they mentioned the opposition
more generally and so i don't think you
can point uh to what the prime minister
said as the cause of that you certainly
can't blame him for the fact um that mob
were clearly behaving in a totally
unacceptable way for what he said
uh well i think what the prime minister
has done already last week is clarified
what he meant i'm glad you said that
because we've got that that was in
blackpool
i'm talking not about uh the leader of
the opposition's personal
um
record when he was uh when he was dpp uh
and i and i totally understand that he
had nothing to do
personally with those decisions
goes no way far enough yeah well i think
it does because it explains that he
wasn't suggesting that kyocerma
personally individually took the
decision on the jimmy savile prosecution
but kiyosama his own website chamber's
website says he was responsible overall
for the cps in fact kirsten himself
apologized for the cps's failings just
in the same way that the prime minister
has apologized for the failings in
number 10 downing street in the last
couple of years so i don't think what he
said particularly when clarified in the
way that you just demonstrated uh means
that what he said originally and was
misleading you certainly can't say that
what he said in any way prompted
provoked or justified
the harassment and intimidation we saw
last night
it is a ridiculous slur peddled by
right-wing trolls
he just needs to apologize
yeah well the suggestion that kyocerma
personally took a decision on jimmy
savile is a slur
right is untrue um kierstahler is a is a
decent man who is uh director of the cps
uh was doing his best but there were
organizational failings
at the cps which kierstahler himself i
think a few years subsequently um
apologized for so i think you know with
that clarification that the prime
minister made a couple of days later
that is an accurate representation then
of what happened not according and i
don't think in any way justified or
provoked or incited the the terrible and
totally unacceptable harassment and
intimidation of the leader of the
opposition we saw last night this is not
what the mayor of london thinks sadiq
khan said this is what happens when fake
news is amplified and given uh
credibility by people who should know
better but not just him nicholas
sturgeon saying
if he has any decency at all the pm will
now apologize unreservedly and sir ed
davies saying the fact that they were
allegedly shouting jimmy savile shows
that boris johnson's words have real
life consequences yeah well i've
listened to the whole tape and they did
mention jimmy savelle that is true that
was they also spent most of the time
when they were harassing uh poor
kirstarma there talking about julian
assange lockdown
goodness knows what else and the same
people
some of the same people who were
harassing and intimidating kierstarma
had done the same thing
to michael govind to bbc journalist nick
was these are people who've got a i'm
afraid that sadly a track record of
behaving in that appalling way towards
public so those are three leaders who
i've told you who disagree not just
labour smp and lib dems this was a
julian smith mp uh last night what
happened to his drama tonight outside
parliament is
appalling uh is what he said he was
appalling it was appalling and he went
on to say it's really important for our
democracy and for his security that the
false savile slurs made against him are
withdrawn in full not just him we also
heard from tobias ellwood last night and
this is what demaious elwood was saying
apologize please we claim to be the
mother of all parliaments let's stop
this drift towards a trumpian
style of politics from becoming the norm
we are better than this yeah and that is
why last week the prime minister
clarified very clearly is your clip
as your as your clip shot good enough
that he wasn't that he wasn't suggesting
that kiestarma personally took decisions
about jimmy savile but the cps which he
ran overall did have organizational
failings and that's what he was pointing
to
um i've just illustrated with at least
seven people who are all senior members
of whatever party they're a member of
all unite to say prime minister you need
to apologize
yeah well like well i've heard those
comments and you know i've said that and
they're all right terrified are they all
that he look he clarified his comments
i've heard his clarification
last week to make clear what he meant
and i think and the prime minister came
out yesterday and very clearly said
yesterday evening that what happened to
kierstarma that terrible harassment and
intimidation is completely unacceptable
uh whether it's the leader of the
opposition whether it's michael gove
whether it's journalists like nick wad
it just should not be happening
on our streets and i'm glad that the
police have made arrests as a result we
haven't met before minister and i'm
sorry to put you on the spot here but
you are defending the indefensible
i don't think so i've explained how the
prime minister clarified what he said he
went back on the record a couple of days
after he made the initial remarks
to make sure there was no
misunderstanding because the thing he
said i think it was monday of last week
that the first clip you played in
parliament could have been misconstrued
as suggesting that kierstama personally
took a decision
those are the slur online slurs that
kirsten himself referred to and the
prime minister quite rightly came back
and clarified that is not what he meant
uh he was talking about the general
responsibility for the organization not
the any specific personal involvement so
he went back and he rightly clarified
that within a couple of days to make
sure there was no misunderstanding the
second most important person in
government his next door neighbor also
said that he would not have said it
yeah he did say that that's right okay
um everybody apart from the prime
minister and it would seem you today uh
feel that it
the leader of the opposition deserves an
apology
well i mean the chancellor didn't say he
deserves an apology he said he wouldn't
personally um have said it and people
make their own choices about what to say
um but i think you know if you look at
his clarification
look i mean it's his choice to make the
comment that he made um
in the heat of the debate uh he
clarified a couple of days later exactly
what he meant but there is no way anyone
reasonably can suggest that what he said
incited or justified or prompted a list
of people who think that it is
reasonable to make that i don't think i
don't think you can
make the leap
from commenting on someone's record as
dpp um or commenting on what happened to
the dpp while he was in charge of it um
being clear that it wasn't him
personally who took the decision on
jimmy savile um to harassment and
intimidation so just to clarify the
mayor of london the leader of the
scottish nationals the leader of the
liberal democrats a very senior
conservative who used to be a minister
uh and a chief whip and the uh chairman
of the defence select committee are all
wrong
yeah i just don't think you can you can
say that the comments the prime minister
made about kirsten's record as dpp or
the crown prosecution services record
can can reasonably be said to have
prompted
the terrible harassment and intimidation
that we just saw people get had their
record criticized the whole time who
criticized the prime minister's record
the whole time politicians get
criticized the whole time and you don't
sort of say well that justifies
a mob surrounding the politician in the
way that we just saw
oh i'm not that's not what i'm saying to
you what i'm saying to you is are all of
these people that i've quoted to you who
feel so strongly about it that they
actually put it into writing on twitter
last night are they all wrong
yeah look as i said i don't think you
can make a link reasonably between what
the prime minister said and the
harassment and intimidation this group
of people there were talking about a
number of things beyond as well as jimmy
savile they're people who have harassed
other
public figures including journalists
over the last uh year or two and so i
don't think you could make that living
when it came to the journalists and when
it came to other people that they were
harassing did they mention jimmy savile
then
well they mentioned all kinds of things
as they did
well no because that wasn't an issue at
the time but
the harassment exactly the hang on the
harassment last night they were talking
about a whole number of things they
talked about they mostly talk about
julian assange if you listen to the
entire clip they were mostly going on
about julian assange for some reason
they were harassing the leader of her
majesty's opposition which is totally
unacceptable
where he needed to get police protection
he needed to be whisked off in a police
vehicle they talked to him about jimmy
savile
and that was brought up by the prime
minister at the dispatch box last week
the uh deputy the um shadow foreign
secretary caught up in the melee as well
several people from all uh persuasions
of parliament and up in scotland as well
and the mayor of london all saying this
is unacceptable and it's a direct result
of what happened with the prime
minister's comments on jimmy savile and
he needs to apologize
well i i i are defending the
indefensible there is no way the leader
of the opposition or any mp in public
life or indeed anyone at all including
journalists
should suffer the kind of intimidation
and harassment that kierstarma uh
suffered on the clip that you're you're
showing no that should happen it's
totally wrong however i don't think you
can say that that was caused by the
prime minister's comments because these
people because these
who undertook that terrible intimidation
and harassment are people who've got a
long track record of doing exactly the
same thing they've been doing that long
before the prime minister made a
reference to jimmy savage are you doing
it to people in my case if the prime
minister didn't think he was wrong why
did he clarify the situation in
blackpool well he clarified the
situation because i think the comments
he made the previous monday
were capable of being potentially
misinterpreted as meaning that
kierstarma had individually somehow been
involved in that case she's not which is
not true yeah which which is not true he
wasn't and there are there have been
online uh slurs as kiersten
what he said could have been
misinterpreted that way and that is why
he came out in blackpool
in the second clip you played very
clearly saying that he's not he was not
suggesting and does not suggest okay
that kirstarma personally got involved
in that but he obviously was responsible
for the cps as a whole and kierstarma
himself subsequently apologize for the
cps's failings in this area okay let's
talk about the online safety bill which
is why you're here today i'm sure my
viewers have their own views on what
happened last night
robust age verification measures is what
being told about the build will that go
far enough
yes it will this is a huge um step
forward to protect children
we are very worried about the way that
large numbers of children
access pornography sometimes extreme
pornography i think 51
of 11 to 13 year olds
have accessed uh porn online which is of
enormous concern to parents we think
that is completely wrong and the
measures we're going to be introducing
to parliament shortly in the updated
online safety bill will impose an
absolute obligation uh on companies all
companies
carrying pornography whether it's
user-generated content on social media
or commercial pornography sites it'll
cover everything will be required to
make sure uh people under the age of 18
uh children cannot access pornography
it'll be the first time
in this country we've legislated in that
way
and we know parents will welcome this
the police will welcome it teachers will
welcome it and it's a massive step
forward for protecting our children okay
um we've been talking about it for a
decade not likely to come in until about
2025. uh why is it taking so long well
there were some provisions in the
digital economy act about four years ago
three years ago and but those didn't go
far enough they didn't cover for example
social media platforms which obviously
is a huge source of pornography that
children end up looking at so we decided
we needed to go a lot further and cover
all forms of
online pornography which this so we took
the opportunity of updating it in this
new bill we intend to introduce this new
bill to parliament in the coming weeks
uh we hope it will have very broad-based
uh cross-party support we'll get it
through parliament as quickly as we
possibly can i hope this calendar year
through both houses and then get it
implemented as quickly after that as we
can so it's a huge step forward to
protect children i think 80 percent of
adults
support the idea of age verification
that is to say making sure that people
under 18 can't see pornography so
there's huge public support for this and
you know we've seen stories about sexual
harassment sexual assaults in schools
increasing in recent years part of the
reason for that the police think is the
exposure
of pornography to children and that's
why it's so important that we take this
like very firm step to make sure they
just can't see this sort of material
online under the age of 18. okay i'm a
pussycat really so let's can i play some
music to finish
if you'd like
[Music]
the prime minister likes it apparently
so i hear yeah he sang it to his new
head of comms so i hear yeah do you
think he's taking the mickey out of all
of us
no i don't i think it was a moment of
lightness in what was always quite a
stressful time
for a lot of people in public life and i
don't think we should
criticize somebody for a moment of
levity during what is probably quite a
stressful working day it's not in his
gift though is it really whether he
survives or not
well uh you know we'll we'll see what
happens but i i hope and expect that he
will
and i don't think we should say we
didn't criticize someone for for having
a moment of lightness i think
everybody's working day i hope including
yours there are moments of lightness in
what can be quite a stressful yes there
are what about you not coming on this
show either i have yes yeah exactly i
need to be singing after this um but
look i mean i don't sing generally but
uh except in the shower um but everyone
needs needs away i think of of
letting off steam i mean all of us i
think in different ways have quite
stressful working lives trust me you
wouldn't want me to sing
maybe i remember alok sharma agreeing to
do islands in the stream with me at
karaoke at christmas once
uh
thankfully for everybody the pandemic
happened you didn't you didn't keep your
maybe next year with you nice to talk to
you thanks very much for coming in thank
you look at front pages for you this
morning starting with the guardian
newspaper uh that leading with criticism
of the prime minister for his comments
to secure stammer about jamie's jimmy
savile forgive me after the labour
leader was confronted by angry
protesters outside the house of commons
it's the same story for the metro their
headline kia flees hate mob likewise the
i which reads police rescue stammer from
mob as pm faces crunch 48 hours while
the express quotes boris johnson
maintaining that he and rishi sunak are
a united front after rumors the
chancellor wants his job
away from those troubles the prime
minister writes for the times insisting
britain will not flinch over the
possibility of conflict in ukraine
a reminder that on thursday nine o'clock
joined in the studio by the education
secretary nadim zahawi who will be
answering your questions you can tweet
the questions you want to put to him
actually we've had thousands literally
thousands already but if you've got a
burning question
you would like to put to the education
secretary then do get in touch he should
have been with us yesterday recovering
from kovid he's much much better one of
his first decisions is to come and talk
to you lovely lot on our program on
thursday morning at nine o'clock
meantime breaking news in the last few
moments the oil giant bp has just
published its latest results our
business correspondent helena is here
what they're saying at morning okay so
yeah the annual results uh from bp for
the year for last year 2021 profits of
12.8 billion pounds big really big uh
bigger certainly than it was in 2020 but
there was a big drop in oil prices in
2020 bigger than it was prior to the
pandemic as well now it's set to be
quite controversial this morning and you
might ask why it's not particularly
controversial normally for large
companies to make big profits but it
will be controversial today because the
very forces that are driving these big
profits for bp that soaring wholesale
price of oil and gas that we've been
hearing so much about is the very forces
that are driving a lot of families into
desperately desperately difficult times
at the moment exactly that okay we heard
just last week didn't we that the
off-gem price cap that's the the price
of limit if you like that the regulator
puts on energy bills to try and protect
vulnerable customers we heard last week
because this price is soaring so high
that cap has to go up it's going up by
54 it means about 700 pounds roughly on
average per household extra every single
year and you know it's really
dire for a lot of families predictions
of something like a quarter of
households now heading into fuel poverty
very very serious so a lot of people
will be asking in this circumstance is
it ethical is it right that essentially
the seller of that wholesale oil and gas
bp and others are making uh such large
profits some of the language as well has
been really controversial okay the uh
the the boss of bp describing the
business as a cash machine recently
which i think some people have said is
is deeply insensitive given the uh
situation that we're all in it will
definitely heighten calls for what's
been called a windfall tax that's
something labour want to see essentially
a one-off tax on these big profits use
some of that money to help poorer
families but there's lots of
controversial difficult things about
that as well bp lost a lot of money last
year they say that the only people to
lose from that are their shareholders
mainly of whom are actually pension
funds so it is complicated okay but
certainly a lot of discussion on this
today i know you're going to get lots of
reaction for us but for now thanks very
much today thanks a lot still to come on
the programme for this hour is the prime
minister's wife carrie johnson a victim
of misogyny i'll be discussing that with
ash sarkar and scotty nell hughes in
just a few moments
we'll have more on the government's
plans to legally force pornographic
websites to check the age of users
the new normal speaking to an etiquette
expert about how some of us working from
home are boosting our images on zoom
[Music]
boris johnson's warned president putin
that invading ukraine would only
strengthen nato
it comes as president putin has warned
european countries that they will be
drawn into military conflict if ukraine
joins nato following his meeting with
the a french not really a meeting was it
with a french president emmanuel macron
yesterday may as well have stayed in
paris
if ukraine would be in nato and tries to
retake crimea militarily european
countries will automatically be drawn
into military conflict with russia
of course nato's armament potential and
russia's are not comparable and we
understand that but we also understand
that russia is one of the leading
nuclear powers and ahead of many in its
modernity
there will be no winners
alex standing by for us now in kiev hi
um alex so we've heard what macron has
been up to speaking to the russians
meantime our prime minister is waving
his finger from the sidelines
uh that's right he is warning uh
president putin of the catastrophic
nature of an invasion if he does decide
uh that course of action he is also
saying that uh uh the uk and nato allah
allies will bolster
their allies in eastern europe so
he's kind of basically saying to
president putin the stakes are extremely
high if you do do this it will be an
extremely risky course of action that
you will pay dearly for not just with
sanctions but you'll also give a reson
detroit
for nato as well a reason for it to
continue and to fortify itself all of
the things that president putin of
course is trying to stop uh from
happening as he kind of tries to
rearrange the furniture of the sort of
european uh security architecture that
was negotiated after the collapse of the
soviet union in
1991 but of course the diplomacy
continues president macron
is uh on his way here he's probably
arrived by now he's due at the
presidential palace for his meeting with
president uh zelensky in the next couple
of hours
or so and i'm sure he will appraise the
president of that marathon meeting that
he had with putin unusual not just in
terms of it length about five hours but
uh also for the fact that no aids were
present but all the time of course the
spectre of an invasion remains those
hundred and thirty thousand troops still
massed on the border okay alex thank you
uh west ham united footballer kurt zuma
says he is deeply sorry after pictures
immersing him kicking
more than kicking his pet cat across his
kitchen floor on sunday
these are the images on the front of the
sun newspaper it was filmed by his
brother
they put it up on social media he was
slapping his cat in the face in this
video that was obtained by the son his
brother believed to have filmed the
incident as it said inside the defenders
home before posting it to snapchat how
stupid is that a day after zuma appeared
for west ham in the fa cup well uh iva
standing by for us now with more
information hi iva i mean this beggars
belief
frankly uh bizarre we're not going to
show the full video um but we are going
to show some still frames from it which
i should warn that some viewers might
find upsetting kurt zuma can be seen
dropping his cat and kicking it with
quite some force across his kitchen
floor
like a goalkeeper would do after picking
up the ball
he's also seen the west ham stars also
seen chasing his cat around his house
hurling shoes at it even at one point
slapping it in the face again really
quite forcefully all the while laughter
can be heard in the background of this
video it was filmed on sunday uploaded
to snapchat and since then the former
chelsea player has issued a groveling
statement quite a lengthy one
he says
i want to apologize for my actions there
are no excuses for my behavior which i
sincerely regret i also want to say how
deeply sorry sorry i am to anyone who is
upset by the video i would like to
assure everyone that our two cats are
perfectly fine and healthy they are
loved and cherished by our entire family
and this behavior was an isolated
incident that will not happen again now
his club west ham have publicly
condemned his actions and the footage
though and have vowed to investigate
this
internally rspca have also spoken out
again against it so i think there could
well be some repercussions to come
okay do we know where the cat is
uh we don't but according to kurt zuma
it's alive and well still in his house
but as i say uh some potential
repercussions because the rspca have
said they may well investigate if they
uh receive any complaints
makes my blood boil this sort of stuff
thanks very much indeed thanks a lot iva
cat's this big he is a professional
footballer and he boots it across the
kitchen allegedly and his brother thinks
it's so funny not only does he take the
video but he then posts it on snapchat
because they think they've done nothing
wrong
allegedly let's look at some of today's
other headlines for you know okay this
is literally the craziest thing i've
ever seen this plane is parked at the
gate and the wind is so bad here in
iceland that it's just rocking back and
forth
tragic story about professional
skateboarder josh newman among four men
killed when their sightseeing plane
crashed into a lake
in iceland more than a thousand search
and rescue personnel helped hunt for the
aircraft when it disappeared from
radar mps are calling on big companies
to publish data on whether employees
from ethnic minorities are paid less
than their white colleagues the chair of
the women and equalities committee said
there was a clear impetus to report
disparities
now a slightly stranger sport and take a
quick look at this
oh show off
that's taking doing a plank to a whole
new level isn't it it's kai sanmeyer
from germany he set a new world record
for hula hooping while planking
six minutes and 34 seconds he held his
plank for almost double the previous
record for the attempt to count he had
to be filmed from several angles with
two witnesses present and he had to do
it all in
public
you've got to give it to him haven't you
that's amazing
now the brit awards returned to london's
o2 arena tonight with a star-studded
lineup of live performances it's a
battle of the old guard versus the
rising stars of the pop world this year
as the likes of adele and ed sheeran
look to fend off competition from a
newer politically charged wave of talent
our arts and entertainment correspondent
katie spencer reports
it's been six years since adele last
left the brit awards clutching armfuls
of trophies now she's back
30 might have been the best selling
album of last year but can her brand of
popular pop
i need a thing
really beat the politics of rapper dave
joy crooks who's up for two brits says
artists should be saying something
meaningful
when sue gray's busy so am i there are
artists that have always written about
what's going on around them
stars who are attending this year's
brits will notice some big changes
who gets one of these has changed this
year and so non-binary artists like sam
smith aren't excluded there's no best
male no best female instead to address
criticism that they've had in recent
years that they aren't reflecting what
young people are actually listening to
this year there's four new categories
alternative
[Music]
although fans are a little rough that no
r b singer has actually made the
shortlist
out of those categories organizers are
hoping to stay relevant by letting tick
tock users vote for who wins
and tick tock is how a1 and j1 found
fame whilst one of them was still at
school during the pandemics when i put
on tip top and i was getting the
reception i was getting i was like
this is this has never happened to you
before that this is crazy
new host mo gilligan expects he'll still
have to do some wrangling
if anyone comes to your party like i'll
tell you where you can get the wi-fi and
the charger but hey if you're sick in
the toilet you gotta clean it up in it
it's your mess a bad habit
in a strong year for music we'll find
out tonight whether politics or pop wins
out katie spencer sky news
oh gotta love a bit of ed sheeran first
thing in the morning haven't you now
it's also a big day in the world of film
today the 2022 oscar nominations are
announced later and it could be the
first time that a netflix movie wins the
best picture prize with power of the dog
currently the book is favorite to win
and there's a big british contingent in
the running for the top acting award
this year including benedict cumberbatch
andrew garfield and of course olivia
coleman
but the oscars have had their limelight
stolen already as the razzies that's the
golden raspberry awards for the biggest
cinematic failures of the year have
released their nominations already in
this characteristically bizarre video
announcement and it's not good news for
bruce willis who according to the
razzies team has been in so many bad
films in one year that he has his own
category worst performance by bruce
willis in a 2021 movie
quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
band of rain through central parts
separating the cold blustery north from
the milder south
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
a banksy mural is to be removed from its
home in wales and taken to a secure
location after attempts by fanatics to
damage the artwork i think they probably
try to take a little bit of it rather
than damaging it season's greetings drew
plenty of attention when it first
appeared on the outside of a steel
workers
private garage in port talbot in
december of 2018 and it eventually had
to be fenced off it depicts a message
about the impact of pollution on
communities and shows a child appearing
to play
in the snow certainly holding his arms
up as it starts to snow but it turns out
to be falling ash and smoke
from a skip fire as you can see
taken to a secure place for protection
coming up is the prime minister's wife
carrie johnson a victim of misogyny
we'll have more on that in just a few
moments tom
[Music]
hi everyone a very good morning to you
welcome to the breakfast programme on
sky the technology minister has defended
boris johnson over spreading claims
about zakir stamos saying that last
night's confrontation with a mob was not
due to the pm's comments about jimmy
savile
the russian president vladimir putin has
warned europe over enlarging nato but
boris johnson says britain won't flinch
west ham united footballer kurt zuma has
said he is deeply sorry after pictures
emerged of him kicking his cat across
his kitchen floor
let's talk about chris philp should we
he has uh condemned last night's
shocking scenes in westminster when the
labour leader sakia starmer was pursued
by a mob hurling abuse at him about the
pedophile jimmy savile but mr philp
defended the prime minister and told
this program that the confrontation was
not because of boris johnson's comments
in the commons several party leaders and
senior tourists are claiming boris
johnson fueled it saying words have an
impact
i don't think you can say that's why it
happened because some of the people
involved in that um that fracker you
showed a second ago you know that they
were
previously you know they were talking
about have previously done similar
things to people like michael gove and
bbc journalist uh nick watt
i've listened to i've listened i've
listened to the whole tape i listened to
the whole tape and they did mention
jimmy savile they did mention that they
also mentioned julian assange repeatedly
they mentioned
covid they mentioned the opposition more
generally and so i don't think you can
point uh to what the prime minister said
as the cause of that you certainly can't
blame him for the fact um that mob were
clearly behaving in a totally
unacceptable way
it's gonna haunt him isn't it so another
minister coming out having to defend the
prime minister's behavior this time over
those jimmy savile comments from last
week which as chris phelps said the
prime minister has clarified saying that
he doesn't think kyrastama was directly
responsible for the decision not to
prosecute jimmy savile he just headed
the organization and that had
that had been involved in it but
he did not apologize we now have as far
as i can tell 10 conservatives on record
criticizing the prime minister over
those comments um julian smith former
cabinet minister saying it's appalling
it's a problem for democracy a newly
elected mp robert largan who as far as i
can see has not been critical of the
prime minister much before saying that
these words echo beyond parliament so
you do wonder if the prime minister who
for now number 10 tell me he's standing
by what he said last night all forms of
harassment are appalling no one should
be harassed but isn't going any further
than that you do wonder if that line is
going to hold okay we'll see uh
tomorrow's take at nine o'clock looking
forward to it thank you very much indeed
well as boris johnson has faced mounting
criticism over his conduct in recent
weeks so too has his wife carrie she's
been accused of having too much
influence at number 10. but she says
she's been the target of a brutal
briefing campaign by her husband's
enemies um the health secretary sajid
javid said recent comments made about
carrie in a biography written by the
tory p lord ashcroft were misogynistic
and sexist so what on earth is going on
joining us to discuss it is ash sarkar a
contributing editor at navora media and
the political commentator and journalist
scotty nell hughes let's go to you ash
first of all if i may
what do you make of what's going on
i think we have to take some of the
ashcroft claims with a hefty pinch of
salt his party piece
is writing these books which have got
enough salacious details in them that it
effectively torpedoes the reputation of
a prime minister we saw that with his
book call me dave with that memorable
story about david cameron and
allegations of what happened with a dead
pig's head what matters is less whether
or not those claims are true and more
about whether or not they emerge into a
context where people want to believe
them and i think with these claims about
carrie johnson what's clear is that
people want to believe these claims
because the prime minister's authority
his sense that he takes his
responsibilities for the operation of
downing street seriously are in absolute
tatters
okay uh let's bring in nelly uh nell
should we um scotty let's call you
scotty um as we normally do it's good to
see you this morning thank you for
staying up as always we really
appreciate it do uh first ladies find
themselves in a similar position are
they a target too
well absolutely and political wives have
this impossible set of expectations
whether you're talking about melania
trump all the way to hillary clinton and
depending on how much involvement they
want to have in their husbands political
roles but make no mistake to say that a
wife if it is a good partnership a good
marriage that she does not have
influence is absolutely naive and i
think they actually damaged the
credibility when the statement was put
out that she plays no role in government
i think that's insulting i think if it
is a good healthy newlywed marriage
that absolutely she has his ear she is
able to advise him because that is what
a partnership is and but realize the
only reason that we're facing this
criticism right now of carrie to the
amount that we are is because her
husband is unpopular uh that while there
has been some in the past this is mainly
being used as a political weapon to hurt
him it's less about her and her actions
they're just that those that are trying
to to call borshon style for his actions
and his irresponsibility in handling
different situations these past few
months are using her to hurt him whether
it works or not i don't know but this
idea that it's misogynistic i think
that's a question the only reason that
may bring sexism into this issue is that
you don't see the same type of criticism
for these spouses who are male of
politicians whether it be american or
british we don't see any criticism of
the second gentleman in fact very rarely
hear anything about douglas imhof here
in the united states so that is the only
place where i think sexism plays the
rules but make no mistake this is more
about the actions of boris johnson and
the criticism he's facing and just being
his wife being used as a tool against
him rather than her actions herself
what do you think on that um actually i
mean to that point we certainly never
heard much
criticism about mr may did we i think
the only thing we knew about him was
that he took the bins out
i mean we didn't hear much criticism of
dennis thatcher who was famous for
spending more time with his golf clubs
than he did at downing street or indeed
uh philip may um but i i would err um on
the side of caution here before making
big sweeping statements because of
course you did have under new labor the
husbands of female cabinet ministers
coming under fire
there was a famous expenses story i
think involving the husband of jackie
smith if i recall correctly
and that was an instance where a female
politician's husband was used to damage
her reputation the thing i would also
encourage us to do is think about the
specifics of this situation because
carrie johnson yes i do think that some
of these criticisms are motivated by
misogyny but she is also a political
operator in her own right she had a
political career before she became
involved with boris johnson and it does
seem that some aspect of that has
continued since they've been married one
of the core allegations around partygate
is that she hosted what was essentially
a victory party in the downing street
flat celebrating the departure of
dominic cummings who she considered to
be her political opponent within the
downing street operation there was also
the hire of allegra stratton in that
prime minister's spokesperson role
she was considered to be a close friend
of carrie johnson so i think that here's
where we get to the sticky point which
is yes i do think that the spouses the
partners of prime ministers can come
under undue scrutiny but in this
instance you also have carrie johnson
operating as her own political actor and
we don't have the normal methods of
holding her accountable the same way we
would a minister or a spad or somebody
who is employed by the prime minister
and i think that that's why the coverage
has taken this more hostile tone
okay um and scotty i mean we we do see
um
first ladies that actually really quite
fancy the top job as well don't we
if we look back not that far in history
absolutely and here we have to recognize
this that's probably one of the reasons
why boris johnson fell in love with
carrie in the first place was her
activism the fact that he could hold
that type of conversation with her so
it's just a natural role for them
together to play as a partner which in
reality looks good look at bill and
hillary clinton and a lot of people say
that she actually was the good the more
serious side when it came to his ruling
when he was here in the united states
and hence why she could launch her own
presidential campaign following so the
same things that she's been criticized
for might be one of the main reasons why
boris first was attracted to her and has
built this relationship with her is
because of her knowledge and her
activism so it would be quite natural
for her to continue into that role not
only as an activist but as the first
first lady of great britain
okay good to talk to both of you ladies
thank you so much much appreciated
now under new online safety rules
websites that publish pornographic
material will be legally required to
verify users are over the age of 18.
joining us now is navi diop the chief of
the gender and human rights branch at
the united nations population fund hello
to you thank you for joining us
on the program this morning um we all
want of course a safer internet do you
think that we are heading in the right
direction
uh
thank you so much for inviting me i
think so because there is more and more
government actually uh recognizing that
there is an issue here
and that the online world is a new
frontier for gender-based violence and
something must be done
so uh unfpa has launched a
campaign a bodywrite campaign
actually to bring attention and
awareness on that particular issue of
online violence because nearly 40
percent of
women have experienced it personally and
it has real life repercussions
what exactly is online violence
online violence is actually using
the internet space
uh and uh trying to uh you know uh
really um
abuse
actually uh women and girls it's
targeting mostly uh you know uh women
and girls globally but there is of
course some groups that are more
vulnerable to online violence
for example women girls ethnic
minorities
lgbtqi
community often face the most abused
things young people who spends most time
online are also especially vulnerable to
that kind of violence and it's a
violation of human rights it is
typically highly sexualized and range
from online harassment to blackmail and
exploitation
okay uh it's so good of you to take the
time to explain that to us this morning
thank you very much indeed for joining
us from new york this morning
fantastic backdrop there wasn't as she
was talking to us and as hybrid working
appears to be
here to stay for many of us research
suggests some staff working from home
have started using clever roses to make
themselves look busier than they really
are on zoom let's talk about it should
we joining us um
to maybe try and give us an idea about
how to convince our bosses online that
we know what we're talking about is
etiquette expert william hanson hi
william it's great to see you thank you
for joining us on the program what are
your top tips
well i think the first one is don't sit
too close and this is particularly true
if you have a laptop rather than a
desktop is that there is a temptation to
sit really close to it and all the
research shows that actually what that
does is when you appear on the other
person's screen or other people's screen
as it triggers the other people's
amygdala the part of our brain that
makes us want to all step back and
disappear because we do feel that you
have en entered our personal space just
as if i came up to you in real life and
stood really close to you your amygdala
would be triggered and you would want to
step back and it gives
on zoom it can still trigger the
amygdala and give you that sort of the
other person the sense of
threat that you you are coming too close
so try to sit back with with as much
space around you as possible without it
looking like you're sitting the other
side of the room
and what about i don't sure if you can
see us this morning what about if you're
trying to be very cerebral and so you
know i sort of put my glasses on and
i've got the bookcase behind me is that
just trying too hard
well if look if that is your backdrop
and that's a genuine backdrop it's fine
uh but if you have sort of put one of
these sort of uh fancy backdrops on to
make it look like you're somewhere else
uh you know the one that really
irritates me is when you see people uh
with the golden gate bridge behind them
for example they're clearly not sitting
in san francisco it's it's a fake
backdrop uh we don't need it uh but if
it is if you have got a bookcase behind
you that's fine glasses you've got to be
careful with though on zoom because of
course you have to completely focus on
as you should be on what yeah the
meeting that you are in because if
you're sort of scrolling through windows
and different things are appearing often
people can see the other windows in your
glasses and so the game is up that
you're not focusing on them
but what about if i'm trying to pretend
that i'm on um holiday what about then
uh well um look you shouldn't really you
know this this research also shows that
people are answering calls on on
pelotons and exercise bikes
to show that they're productive
similarly if you're answering a call
when you're on holiday well fair enough
your choice your holiday um but perhaps
you're not going to be focusing that
much on what's going on and with any
meeting in real life or on zoom you need
to focus on the people
that are there
okay i'm going to put my glasses back on
i think i think this makes me look quite
cerebral actually there we go and i'm in
a tv studio as well so this is my sort
of setting now if you will um but you
have to i suppose you have to be quite
careful as well for people to focus as
you were saying on you as opposed to
what's going on in in the background and
it depends who your audience is
exactly and i'm sure we we've probably
all uh slightly changed where we've done
uh zooms from over the last two years
based on who we are speaking to and i
think actually for etiquette coaches
like me it's been interesting to sort of
see the change in etiquette over the
last two years and initially sort of in
march and april 2020
i and others were saying you know you
don't really comment on uh anything that
you can see you try and have as plain a
background as possible but i think then
it quickly changed because we weren't
going into people's homes socially or
professionally we were confined to our
own home and actually we were so used to
doing video calls a year two years later
that really now for small talk
especially when you're waiting for
people to connect uh others on the call
anything that you can see in someone's
background is fair game to use for
polite civil positive uh small talk so
if you can see it you can talk about it
whereas if i didn't want you to see it
or know it was there i would of course
change my background
yeah i once interviewed um
the the would-be uh us president former
first lady of course hillary clinton um
and we both agreed that we looked very
proper from here but we both had our
sloppy joes on underneath is that
acceptable
uh well it all goes on my my suggestion
is no because you never know what might
happen a mouse might run in the room the
laptop might fall down someone might
come to the door you suddenly need to
get up uh and and then the game is up
and then all your sort of professional
image has been quashed and for the extra
30 seconds uh it takes to put on some
you know trousers or something that
matches the the top half uh i think it's
probably not worth it but look if it's
good enough for
um you know the former secretary of
state of america then that's fine oh
there we go and what about when um is
there a polite way of telling people
that they're on mute
all day every day i say to my team
you're on mute
uh yeah well i you can unzoom if you're
the host of a meeting you can request
that somebody unmute i think that's sort
of a slightly less passive-aggressive
way uh to do it than sort of rather uh
yes uh for lawnly saying you're on mute
still
uh but
hopefully
this will change as people get even more
used to zoom but that said we've had two
years of asking if people could take
themselves off mute so maybe it won't
change maybe that bit is here to stay
and what about finally before i let you
go what about the the social um
appropriateness of not having your
camera on
oh no i think no if you're especially if
you're invited to a zoom you know that
there is part of the given is that you
are going to be in vision and not having
it on or blurring your background
perhaps sort of is is more suspicious i
think uh than if you sort of have your
camera on or show something in the
background i think if you wanted a just
an audio only call pick up the phone but
zoom is by and large it's a video call
i
couldn't agree with you more hope you're
having a lovely holiday and hopefully
we'll see you very soon thank you very
much indeed for your top tips always
much appreciated
thank you
thanks look very quick chat um with um
tamara while we're here um what did you
make of what the minister had to say
this morning tomorrow good morning very
strong defense of boris johnson saying
that he cannot be blamed for what
happened between kirstama and those
protesters last night the very ugly
scenes where he was mobbed by anti-vaxx
protesters shouting at one point about
jimmy savile now the point that chris
philp the minister made is that these
protesters have been around westminster
for a few months now protesting mainly
about anti-vaxx
protests and they were shouting about
julian assange and various other things
and so he was making the point that
perhaps they would have seized on
anything and they have intimidated
journalists and other politicians
including conservatives but we now have
10 tories on the record saying the prime
minister needs to apologize and take
responsibility for the comments he made
and the impact they have outside
westminster yes many of those are people
who criticized the prime minister before
but um the pressure seems to be building
on the prime minister to not just
clarify his comments but to apologize
for them okay more to come in just a few
moments here on sky news distinction
[Music]
you